[Music]
yo hey we're here we might be drunk
welcome how are you we got Natasha
Leggero here one of our favorites good
to have you very happy to have you thank
you guys for having me thanks for coming
in from L.A yeah uh man it's it's really
hard to get around here are you one of
those La people that hates coming I
lived here and it's just bringing back
memories of just pounding the pavement
crying I feel like that was me for like
five years in New York that's most of it
in the beginning and then I sat at a sad
sandwich shop and just ate an egg salad
sandwich because it was like snow
raining and and you guys were like right
across the street so you know I was like
waiting for an hour is it right it's
like snow I thought that was part of the
song
that's what I was saying I was like
bringing back memories and then then I
was like this happens to me too now like
I sat down because you don't sit down by
yourself in public in L.A you know and I
sit down and then this like old man was
sitting at this like communal table
across from me it was Al Franken no it
wasn't Al Franken but the guy did smile
at me this is starting happening to me
where I'm like
do you think that this would ever happen
like men in their 60s I don't know what
kind of vibe I'm giving off well I
probably thought you were a Disney
princess
the outfit maybe I don't know but yeah
thank you Mark no but you look great
fashion look at me it comes naturally to
you yeah I got 11 year old skateboarder
come on
pick every male comic I know Sam's
wearing like a nice adult shirt he's got
a nice jacket going yeah I had to bring
him when Natasha I should have brought
it I was on a date last week when
Natasha text me to come on and literally
10 minutes before she texts me this girl
goes you know who my favorite comedian
is no that was Joshua
oh come on later she said Michelle wolf
you must have gotten some action after
like showing her that's as much as I
should have first show in that time I
feel like that should have gotten me
more he just got pegged yeah
that was after I showed her yeah but
yeah uh I opened for you year do you
remember that at Caroline's you know
people say this to me and I really have
a bad memory Mark all right I was not
remember I was a new comic was I nice to
you you were so nice Okay and Todd Berry
was a dick and you stood up for me and
I've never forgotten I appreciate it
wait Todd was a dick to you well I I'm
like I was so green and annoying you're
doing the guest spot Mark yeah
this is how long ago this was Todd was
running a letterman so you were like
yeah sure come do five I'm at Caroline's
and I was hosting and I was you know
excited and annoying and uh you guys
went out after and I was like oh where
are we going and Todd's like nah you hey
something like that I mean he was half
joking but half totting
and you were like no no don't worry you
can come and you you said it like off to
the side when he couldn't hear you like
you come you come and I the whole time I
was like I didn't say a word because you
guys were did you come I I weirdly
showed up and just hung out to the side
and we went to some Hotel bar and you
guys talked about show business that is
brave Mark if someone told me to not
come that's I like that well it was
probably a reason when a woman tells me
not to come I come instantly so did I
yeah I still came well I'm glad that we
hung out with you and I'm I'm sorry that
you came outside it was fun I mean you
know when you're so new and so green
you're just like watching people who are
successful was thrilling and now you're
are so successful wow but he still
dresses like that and Todd's still
addictive what I saw him last night oh
good tell him I said hi I will all right
I mean Todd is so funny though we love
time let's just let him ask how we want
if you haven't yes that was a fan he has
so many albums that are just like lights
out I used to listen to him when I
started in New Orleans yeah I was a huge
fan but but what are we drinking there
beard you well what was the time I
picked the drinks for you guys but this
time you get to choose your own kind of
and we'll figure out wait it's a taste
test wait a minute
three different stuff three different
prices I haven't even Splurge for this
at the restaurants
like the flight right exactly and
whichever you like best you get a full
glass of or many more oh lovely and we
got the what is that a charcuterie what
do you call that cheese plate yeah I
think the kids called charcutey board
sarkucci
this is amazing all right I did this at
my wedding because I I really wanted to
buy expensive wine and most was like
there was a wine shop shop up the street
called Trader Joe's
I am not giving my guest Trader Joe's
Wine and so I made this huge deal out of
it and then my wedding planners came and
we did a taste test and we all picked
the Trader Joe's no
and here's the worst part of the story I
still bought the expensive wine because
I don't want my friends like I bought
like half expensive ones my friends to
see like we're pouring Trader Joe's you
know Trader Giotto yeah it always has
some names Traders Trader Jose or
something you mentioned Trader Joe's
no but there are three different Mastery
different prices maybe we should all do
the same one at the same time yeah are
they in the right order they have
numbers on them they have numbers on
them they do just choose which one you
like I'm an idiot I'm starting with
three oh geez all right
okay are these also they're all saw
blocks
this was Natasha requested soft Blanc
well you said what is your cocktail and
I don't really drink cocktails I always
expect you for like a martini if I drink
a martini I would definitely vomit it's
five foot one martinis are so strong
they are they are and because the
glasses are not fun to hold no they hate
the glass this is pretty good Loki what
are we starting
okay one has just started to taste like
water to me that's bad right
they always say it's like it's so hard
to drink a whole bottle of water but so
easy to drink a bottle of wine
well said
um this is good I like it and I'm not a
wine guy you're not a wine guy I'm not a
I'm not a white wine guy I like a red
better red is obviously better it just
gives me headaches so I can't oh yeah
it'll kill you in the morning okay
number two we're going for okay A little
Fuller
a little nutty this one tastes more like
um my ex I think I like the the third
one better than the second okay I'm
following you guys leave it's a little
bit like I'm ignorant uh I don't know
like like raw alcohol like they put like
a splash of vodka in it or something
interesting I I feel that yeah it does
besides that all right it's definitely
good after taste it's a little it's got
a sting to it yeah okay number one I
feel like these are all kind of like
flat simple dry something like I maybe
we didn't give you guys the best flat
siblings they're not they're not they're
nothing exotic don't worry okay
much different right
that's dry that's number one that's what
dry is when people say dry yeah I'm
learning
okay he's the best I agree I like I'm a
three person I would say three as well
for three what but what if it's Trader
Joe's
all right so for the big reveal okay I'm
wearing a diaper uh let's go with the
least favorite was number two correct
yes all right well you guys
some taste that is the cheapest one hey
look at us it's the cheapest one all
right cupcake don't ever buy cupcake you
guys
cake Vineyards it's like a budget you
know wine they have they have Pinot
Grigio soft long so everything you need
to grab it
at this when you're going to a party
that you like you hope that no one sees
right because like that is not everyone
knows effectively yes
and then our favorite was number two
number one number one no no no no three
three three three rather so three
was gas stations strangely enough
strangely enough you guys picked the
middle best as your best which is Kim
Crawford I drink this all the time and
also restaurants do not serve cupcake
but they do serve Kim okay actually my
restaurant stays Kim Pro yeah yeah a lot
this is a very popular house soft blonde
because it's good mid-sear and it'll get
you there and it is nice to pair with
like uh with any kind of like like light
meal how much is the Kim Crawford Kim
Crawford is about 25 bucks 25 26.
and then obviously at the uh higher tier
was cake bread sellers at 45.
when you guys said like the oh that's
dry that's dry that's like when you feel
like that that extreme dryness when it's
just been completely like Barrel aged
for like a good amount for as long as a
white wine should be get that wow I
seriously would rather have the
expensive one
down I like the Kim Croft well I I drink
Kim Crawford all the time
maybe it'll be lesser of a hangover too
right now this is the mental part of me
I'm tasting the thank you the second one
we liked and it tastes better now that I
know it's the good one isn't that [ __ ]
up how the mine works yeah we're really
trying what is that cake bread oh no
that's me there you go Americans are
just trash we really are we really are
it just sucks I would think of that
Richard Jenny joke how the French have
the croissant and here in America we go
uh we made a Chris sandwich yes so true
we did even Canada has been I went to
Vancouver and it's even more it's it's
even a little more refined there did you
guys know that in other countries they
have like full maternity leave they oh
yeah in Finland they give you a box it
was full of like um a box the boxes for
your baby to sleep in and then they give
you like all of this like baby supplies
anything you would need you get like 400
days off right a year that you can use
whenever you want you know it's like
America we're just like do your thing
you know like spend for yours don't get
an abortion right I'm not gonna help you
with any of this yeah but this is my
biological father talking to my mom by
the way
wait so your dad's not a lawyer that's
your step no yes
okay all right Comics you know we all
have a story
that's like the most polite way it's a
bumper sticker
yeah well it's true though I mean that
was what really attracted me to
comedians you've dated some Comics but
not even yes dated I always date
comedians but also like just when I
first got to New York or I think it went
from New York I got to L.A and I would
start going to auditions and the actors
were so annoying and I'd be in a green
room with actors and they were just like
all competitive and bragging and boring
and then all of a sudden you go to an
improv audition and like everybody's
funny and yes I mean they're still like
vain [ __ ] but you know at least
they're like funny they're giving back
yeah totally so I just always wanted to
hang out with comedians but then you
start talking to him it's like oh you
got stabbed when you were little oh yeah
yeah some you know someone accosted you
in an alley oh your brother died you
know it's like always something like
there's always an exciting we all have
something that [ __ ] us up but like
there's something about actors having to
hide in other roles that makes me feel
like they don't work on it as much
comedians we have to live with like
ourselves we have to like be in our head
for like who we are on stage so I do
feel like on some level we work a little
more on it than actors oh yeah oh for
sure we work on ourselves ourselves
we have to address this [ __ ] right
they're just like sometimes do you ever
look at someone who's like a really good
actor and like they just looks like it
looks like there's nothing
the best actors have like nothing to say
because they just like become something
else
yeah yeah that's what they do they're
the Ship Shape Shifters yeah you know
they're not real they're chameleons they
say you can always tell an actor from
the glazed look in their eye whenever
someone else is talking oh but maybe
that's comedians too yeah well that's
when you meet a comedian's uh
significant other you're like oh yeah
yeah
let me get back to this unless they're a
comedian yeah that helps that helps
motion is [ __ ] awesome yeah emotional
hilarious your wife what let me guess
did you marry a chef a nanny uh keep
going dominatrix that was yours uh let
me think nurse I'm trying to think of
what male Comics like nurse is very
giving right yeah
um okay let me see uh
it's like you know it's like a real
officey job he hasn't asked her what she
does yet
but you just got married that's oh wait
so what does she do she works in a
marketing but also a comedian oh
yeah
yeah
I'm good
I'm good we gel
good yeah because I think it's really
important to have a someone who at least
understands the lifestyle totally you're
just like on a whim gonna be like I'm
gone Wednesday I'm gone Thursday yeah
I'm gonna be I'm going staying out till
11 you know I remember some girl when I
was coming up this like beautiful model
and she was doing comedy and she was
always getting in these like passionate
fights with her older husband who was
like you can't go out you can't go out
tonight yeah I need to go out to you
know and it was like they were always
fighting oh yeah you don't want that and
a lot of people will be into comedy in
the dating you know that kind of world
and they're like oh I love that you're a
comedian and then when you start getting
serious they're like come on stop that
now and you're like no I'm the same guy
but once you get serious there's some
kind of cut off I had that with a girl
recently where she was like it's the
weekend we should be hanging out and I
was like I have work what do you mean I
work at night and she's like well it's
important to me for I was like let's
just not do this then let's just give up
that fast yes I was like I'm out well I
mean it's your job it's your Lively
three then yeah I'm [ __ ] out it's
really important to me that we spend
weekends together yeah that's a nail in
the coffin right there Kiss of Death you
know Moshe has been going away like he's
away performing all the time but last
week he went to some post-burning Man
parties
for three days that's divorce I mean I
was like I kept asking him I was so
confused by it I'm like are you sure you
want to go to this I go this doesn't
seem like this just seems sounds like
work well it also seems like something
you do like if you're like single it's
like in a hotel I don't know and I'm
like you really would rather do that
than hang out with your cute family then
he explained to me the other night he
was like you know I want to just sit
home and watch The Vow with you but like
I start to feel like if I don't make an
effort to do things like life slips by
and I like for him to feel alive he
needs to be special because it's real
easy for us to just slip into that
cocoon as comedians to just stay home
and watch it so bad though this isn't
even Burning Man though this is like a
post-burning man
that's a lot of Molly talking yeah I
went to Burning Man three times it was
pretty rough whoa three times let's hear
it you know before the pandemic I think
I was just more game yeah I could see
that no I was just kind of like oh it's
cute that's true now I'm just kind of
like no no right no that's not happening
yeah well you try to be adventurous then
you go and right when you get there
you're like what was I thinking this is
a [ __ ] nightmare and motion wanted to
go so bad this year he want or he wanted
to take our kid he went with friends or
what'd he do he go he has like a whole
group he used to work there so he has
like a whole group that he goes with and
he really wanted to take our kid and I
said listen
if you don't take our kid how about you
how about I go how about we do the thing
that you asked me before we got married
and because he he came to me before I
got married he's like what if I just we
can open up the relationship just at
Burning Man and I was like no wait what
that was his pitch because he had never
been in a relationship before ah oh he
was kind of a player he was a player but
also like didn't have much experience so
he didn't know that like that's not okay
and I was so then this past year I said
you know what wait so he can only [ __ ]
around at this Festival no but we said
no yeah but then that was his that was
his pitch but it just he doesn't think
things through
because like then what he goes to like
Reno or he goes to Louisiana wherever
he's doing stand-up and then you know
Raleigh right and how do we know that
he's not gonna like do it there you know
so and we'll see you just want a
monogamous relation husband I would
prefer that just because
it makes it he's like all right no to
burning man but Coachella
I mean I get that it's like a fantasy to
be able to open up your relationship but
for a woman for a mom I mean imagine
like this like you know A lactating
mom's you know sidling up to the bar
trying to like talk to men like this is
not fair to for a woman like open
relationships are definitely it's I
think it's more challenging for the
mother of course especially in that
state so then I tell you no though I
think I think I think women have a
easier well it's easier to get laid as a
lady but not if you're a mom or you're
like I'm not breastfeeding anything have
you heard of this porn category MILF
does pretty well very popular very
popular depending which bar you know
yeah
well anyway the point the point is I
told him if you how about you can go do
whatever you want at Burning Man but in
exchange you don't take our child there
wow that's a great deal I wait wait so
he is allowed to do that or no well then
I like so I told him this and I think he
was like okay he didn't know if I was
kidding or not kidding you know and so
then I told my therapist about it and
she was like when's he leaving and I was
like in two days she's like you should
probably get confirmation like what yeah
yeah yeah so I came to him with it and
he was like Oh I thought you were
kidding I would never want to mess up
our family so that was oh wow
Mark's confused I'm so confused this is
strange he deletes Tinder yeah right
yeah no I got that was a joke what are
you talking about I mean this is
probably one of your first big
relationships right that you just got
married no no I was in a 12 year before
you were yeah I did not see that 12
Years a Slave they made a movie yeah
you were really I was a relationship guy
and then I got out for a couple years
and just you know went nuts and then got
back in oh with a different person yes
yes a man no yeah but now a difference
you're a beautiful uh child did you see
her yeah when I was at your place pull
her up don't pull her up all right don't
pull up any baby I'd believe it I mean
maybe you know Mark's married now but do
you have any advice if he wants yes
maybe have a kid because you have this
new book out uh my book The World
deserves my children
he's beautiful thank you
um I mean art so you want to have a baby
eventually yeah how old is your 31 okay
so my advice is buy 38 she should freeze
her eggs oh really and that's the cut
off and then she's she's an aspiring
comedian or up and coming comedian you
know so I'm assuming that she wants to
keep working on her career I mean 30 to
40. those are your Peak money making you
got that right those are your Peak fun
years yeah those are your Peak
um you know development year so it's
like having baby and then and then being
in a survival mode you know in your your
30s and 40s yeah so and I had my baby at
43 so this this egg technology is is
really cool it's amazing it's it's
giving women like little time on life
yeah of course the the it's giving us
what men have always had right the
ability to start a family second family
in their 70s or whatever you guys want
to do I think Mick Jagger just had a kid
at like a little much yeah come on Mick
what are you doing that is pretty crazy
well he's got this Burning Man ultimatum
I think that's pretty good I didn't
explain that very well you know I only
[ __ ] around to women at the fire
Festival
but yeah so I think Moshe didn't quite
get that like you a relationship is
monogamous I guess for a reason right
well it's a different time too you know
things are all wacky now and fluid you
never know I didn't I didn't know Moshe
was like that he seems like such a adult
you know he does yeah he does but you're
married to him he seems like kind of a
wise guy he doesn't I saw him at the
Improv last time I was in LA and I did
this bit about a terrible hookup story
and he kind of like he was like talking
to me after the uh set and he was like
is that a true story and I said yeah
he's like never go to bed with someone
you wouldn't have lunch with and I was
like wait what that's pretty good that
I know but I was like that's like an
adult thing to say I never thought about
it like that yeah well he does have
wisdom and we have a podcast the endless
honeymoon podcast I've done it it's a
great podcast and yes and I don't
remember who called when you when you
called but like there's always she DM me
she
whoa what was her question I can't
believe I don't remember I think she had
like a breakup and uh we were like
helping her through it or something she
was hot but would you have lunch with
her that's the question how do you find
that out if you'd have lunch with
someone though you can get a Vibe I
think
yeah I don't know well I'm sorry that
one of our callers DM dude
thank you he liked it but all these 20
year olds and even 30 year olds I feel
like they don't have a lot of guidance
and nobody really knows what to do and
especially since covid and you know
everyone wants to be dating they don't
they're sick of online dating right no
one's going out it's like what do you do
it's tough now I I don't uh I don't envy
you as a single man these days he's he's
killing every night on stage in New York
I bet he like it's ups and downs do you
do that thing that got that male Comics
do where you hang out by the bathroom
is that the move now that's where all
the girls go you know they go to the
bathroom and then you can be they can be
like
they're always in the hallway with their
arms crossed good point it's so funny
because like the idea that I would get
off stage and want to talk to some guy
going to the bathroom and like waiting
in line for the bathroom it would never
happen the road is especially in L.A
they're gonna go vomit since for sure
and in other ways too but for for sure
the uh
a hookup by the way I don't like hooking
up on the road either anymore I'm
getting older it's not fun anymore
because I'm like I'm [ __ ] exhausted
usually I'm on the road every week is it
like the waitresses usually or is it
almost never oh that's a bad idea yeah
because you gotta be there the next
night I I open for a comedian I can't
say who it was but he tear it up come
out look in the aisle of the of the see
who was hot and then he would go tell
the waitress get them chicken nachos
and then he would get them like the hot
girls chicken nachos I want to [ __ ] the
woman who's bloated after the show yeah
you're busted Todd Berry
did you get her some jalapeno poppers
too and then he would invite them
backstage afterwards and just kind of
you know just let them figure out who it
was gonna be I don't have that kind of
confidence so I'd be like get her the
chicken nachos and then after I'd be
like where is she oh [ __ ] it wouldn't
work out I wanted off camera I want to
know who it is oh I'll tell you all
right
R.I.P Gallagher
that was a hilarious one where uh there
was like not that many nice obits oh
that's true yeah Gallagher died yeah
yeah when two days ago yeah three days
interesting because like didn't his
brother go on his brother was touring as
Gallagher too that's right yeah I
remember he was a dick by the way how do
you know it's not a great comic right
there's no there's no Carlin too yeah
or maybe it's just Gallagher he's like I
wore up my welcome so was he hated like
what do you think he was like to his
peers like how we like was he like
Carlos mencius I heard he was a dick
everybody that was the buzz about him
that he was a meme or the person that
people yeah but think about how much we
want to love Comics you know like this
is like such a
it's like a family it not to sound corny
but really like you want to love your
fellow Comics so but Comics like [ __ ] on
each other now publicly I just I wasn't
trying to [ __ ] on Carlos Mencia I'm just
saying I remember when I was coming up
people were like we don't like him and I
didn't understand why he's like an
Unapologetic joke thief and he's kind of
got a bad Vibe I feel like you know
where it's like I'm saying if you you
have to do so much for us to turn on you
I feel like the public will turn on you
but Comics rarely turn on other Comics
unless they're really shitty I think Sam
that is not true you don't think so no
because people like talk [ __ ] about
people on their podcasts now Ah that's a
bummer that's we try to avoid it we're
trying I don't do it either but they're
except for Gallagher I apologize
you're one of the greats wait there
weren't any nice obituaries for
Gallagher it was a lot a couple were
like you know he was nice to me one time
you know right right do you think 20
year olds know who that is probably no
no way they don't even know who lost all
our 20 year old listeners after we at Al
Franken on
what was Al Franken drinking
yeah he was drinking that not funny
juice no we have a dignified lady here
oh sorry okay it's the fourth time he's
done it ah sorry I know next time I'll
sit on Samsung all right all right you
like it I do I mean last one last one
I'm used to it I've never seen like
French wine make someone burp
I can declass anything but uh oh you uh
you were on Andrew Dice Clay's show
remember that show that was a good show
yeah oh now we're just like Googling
Like Comics I saw this photo what uh
yeah what's that what was that like how
was dice to work with
um he well at one point I remember he
was like
he was like hey we were doing a bedroom
scene he's like can you give me a
massage like in between and I was in
between takes oh boy and I was like no
I'm gonna and Andrea and Brody was there
that day I was like why don't you ask
Adrian Brody give you a massage and he's
like [ __ ] no I don't you know so now he
just made it sexual right well I mean
but that's the thing like he wasn't
trying to be rude it was just like he's
like hey you know you're in we're in a
bed you know my back hurts whatever oh
boy that's that's the beauty of dice
he's just like he is that he's just like
he's you know he's over the top yeah
right I mean he would go through customs
smoking cigarettes
and they'd be like they'd be like excuse
me sir you're not supposed to be smoking
he's like oh I didn't see the sign
that's hilarious I mean he's just like
who doesn't one of these two yeah with
the X-ray thing going around he's got a
cigarette in there that's that's
hilarious yeah and then it's just like
he gets in a mood and it's just like
walk away walk away you know but he was
a great he's a great father and his kids
really loved him and I think that's
always a good sign I agree yeah I own
for him once and I you know I'm not the
biggest dice guy but I was like he's a
legend I'd like to meet him so I go up
to him and I go Mr dice I'm your feature
just saying hello if there's anything
and he goes you want a photo and I go no
no I'm just saying you know hello and
how much time do you want me to do he
goes give me the phone
all right so I just gave him my phone he
took a photo of us with my phone and
gave it back and I didn't know how much
time to do I mean when you think of the
trajectories of comedians like to to be
to be at the very tops I mean the way he
blamed it it was like one day Madison
Square Garden selling it out the first
one ever the very next day backlash on
New York Times front cover that's right
so I mean that is like a massive like
thing to deal with emotionally and you
know I don't know how people would cope
with something like that it's so funny
that dice is playing MSG like one night
there's like the Knicks or the Rangers
and the next night he's like this chick
is sucking my dick right 20 000 people
but a lot of comedians have played it
since right he started and then he did
the next album's hilarious the day the
laughter yes it's just dice bombing a
Dangerfield for an hour yeah it's kind
of like a weird artistic choice that I
really respect I know Garden to just
eating [ __ ] I I actually have that
record my friend Brendan Walsh gave it
to me and I'll play it when I'm having a
party and I want people to leave
it's like it gives the right cue
jar it's a jarring away if you ever
divorce Moshe put that on
yeah how long have you been married to
Moshe
um seven years
the seven year rich thank you and uh
yeah we have this child now and it's
it's really amazing to have a child you
should do it Mark yeah you think
although most told me I should stop
telling everyone to have a kid well it's
not for everybody yeah but it is once
you have it I promise you I mean unless
you get a [ __ ] up one that's true yeah
we had a bad kid growing up my brother
and he one of my your brother was bad he
was like a problem child is he still bad
or he lives in a van that he put an
address on and he like he spent the
pandemic on probation because he got
into a fight at a gas station parking
lot because he basically he's like and
it's never his fault you know he's like
girl I'm I'm in the I'm in the 7-Eleven
and I just said to this guy I'm like Hey
brother why don't you put on a mask and
and then I'm pumping my gas and the guy
steps to me and you know what's with
because guys like my brother who've been
to court a lot they know what all the
laws are he's like he stopped the little
11 feet of me he kind of knows like what
the cutoff is legally how close someone
can get to you yeah yeah so of course
he's like so you know I pound him in the
face he was so close you know he's in my
he was he was within his feet and then
then he's got his license taken away and
you know it's like always something yeah
yeah heavy you know right I feel bad for
him wait he was pushing the mask or the
other guy was pushing but surprisingly
my brother that's pushing that this guy
wear a mask
you don't hear about the liberal band
exactly exactly out of you for a woman's
right to choose
no let's [ __ ] dance
so I think he's gotten his his license
back now but you know it's it's just
good for him yeah all right so you beat
your other brother are you closer to I'm
close to my other brother yeah but you
know I do I do feel bad that my kid
doesn't have
Playmate you know I mean have you ever
tried to play Make Believe five-year-old
it's exhausting oh that's a lot of work
it's so much work I zone out you know
I'm just not good at it I like like art
activities but she doesn't want to do
that and then you know moshe's just at a
loss he's just like okay we're going to
the mall or like he'll just take her
somewhere you know just to like because
they can you'll wake up at seven they'll
wake up at seven on the weekend you put
you give them TV by the time you wake up
it's been two hours right that's already
how much TV they're supposed to watch in
one day good point then you have from 9
A.M till 8 P.M to fill up it's it's a
lot of time to work well I thought you
were trying to sell him on having a kid
I know right what's the pitch to that
for having a kid because he has a wife
who will uh if if he's lucky give up her
stand-up career to help raise their
child and then he can go on the road
you'll pay for everything you're kind of
you're kind of like you know
while you're [ __ ] making an equip
baby yeah you're gonna quit no I I think
that um you know you're not you're
you're young well yeah all right you're
you're selling it pretty good I'm trying
to sell it I'm not trying to sell I
would like to sell my book though yeah
sell the book that's your real baby so
these are comedic Tales no comedic
essays because it's all real
um uh based on my experience of
motherhood and you know parenting at the
end of the world and freezing my eggs
and I love it you know that's a great
coverage free and paid you know I feel
like no one ever wants to talk about the
people we have to pay to help our kids
the nannies you know you can't really be
like a working professional and not have
people you gotta paying to help you with
your kid unless you have parents or
something parenting at the end of the
world I mean this was a big thing that I
went through because the pandemic
happened and you know you're like taking
care of this thing and the stakes are so
high and then just like if I go get her
a haircut and my potentially or eat eat
dine indoors am I potentially going to
give her long credit you know it's like
every single decision it's like this was
so this was like I'm still traumatized
yeah it was a nightmare time
mothers and like kids who missed Middle
School they probably had oh was it your
whole personality developed in middle
school completely so kids were like in
fifth grade and now they're a freshman
or something it's like so weird it's
weird I just feel so bad and I have so
many friends kids who are like 10 and 12
and they just keep wearing their masks
because that's just how they feel
comfortable now you know yeah it's a
tough time if you're missing your prom
missing your graduation starting College
all that is gone it's not the same
that's a bummer so so I think we have it
you know families sing you know single
men new newlyweds you guys we all have
it where are you at on there my brother
has two infants and he doesn't allow
phones he doesn't allow TV and isn't on
an iPad nothing and well infants no
you're supposed to wait till two sorry I
I don't know what infant means one's
nine and one's four but wait are you
serious yeah
you know children what's the word yeah
at what age should you be giving a kid
uh but these kids are so smart they do
puzzles they write plays they re they've
read more books than I have they do
because they're nine and he doesn't
allow phones no no and it I don't know
how he does it does he have a wife who
doesn't have a day job he she's a doctor
he works from home ah so I guess he
knocks it out at home while working kind
of sounds like he's killing it maybe
it'd be a good a good dad too Mark he's
killing but he's miserable why is he
miserable well it's just a lot of work
it's like she's you know it's like you
ground them from the iPad for like
saying something rude and then you're
like oh wait I wanted you to get on the
iPad yeah me so you're like okay you can
watch the iPad but you know it's it's
it's your it's your down time but again
this is how people did it for thousands
of years and now all of a sudden we're
like that's crazy but they had a bunch
of kids that's true and they raised each
other
oh you're that's that I never thought of
it so we didn't have this is like an
this is like the past 10 years you could
like stick a device with anything in
front of it exactly before you just sent
him outside and they figured it out my
daughter asked me she's like Mom how do
you french kiss
and I go where did you hear that and
then she was like oh I don't know and
then that's like when you just kind of
pivot and change the subject but like
but sometimes on Netflix she's watching
cartoons but they might be for like like
teens or like big teens well she's
definitely not watching Big Mouth I
don't know I have well I have the
settings
okay but then I'm like okay I guess I
have to vet everything you know and then
she starts watching these things on
YouTube I don't know YouTube is the
worst because like I'll hand her a TV
show like Bluey or something and then
all of a sudden she's on the phone and
then I'm listening and there's like some
like it's like bad acting it's like a
mother and two kids pretending the mom's
pretending she's mad at the kids and the
kids are like showing doing some product
it's like some weird like the people no
I don't even know what it is it's a
genre of like people in the Philippines
renting out a mansion and like what I I
don't it's it's so straight I need to
find out what it is and now my daughter
knows it's like these empty mcmansions
that people are renting
is that in the kitchen and they they
like when
I don't know but I was listening I was
reading this article about um you know
Coco melon that's a big one they all
like and so basically there's these
dudes in Silicon Valley and they are
testing the shows so they put a
two-year-old in the room and then in the
corner they have on an iPad uh someone
doing really boring things like pouring
tea or you know just like putting dishes
in a dishwasher and anything anytime the
kid looks at that instead they flag it
so they only want like the things that
grab the kids attentions the most so one
one cartoon that they mentioned this is
in the New York Times one cartoon they
mentioned they said like kids love
school buses but they also love minor
injuries wow so then there's a school
bus that has a bandage wrapped around it
and so like that's how you can get the
kid to not look at the coffee pouring oh
my God we're just helping pedophiles at
this point this is pedophiles like holy
[ __ ] what is that by the way they're
just doing this to adults with the news
sure you're right maybe they're like
maybe these parents are like getting
money to show toys like these are
unprofessional videos and this is all my
kid wants to click on it's it's like and
one day she even goes she goes Mom this
is bad sound right oh wow she knows now
she knew it was like they didn't have
lava and this is just like that is an
L.A kid the quality is low low res but
yeah it's just like so so anyway back to
your brother I mean he's clearly doing
the right thing it's just that takes so
much energy he's an animal I don't know
how he does is there any difference
between like you know showing this [ __ ]
to kids and then adult it's just like
look who Pete Davidson's [ __ ] now and
you're like same [ __ ] same [ __ ] same
[ __ ] they know how to grab us too
sophisticated ourselves you know yeah
I'm sure that well that's what the out
algorithm is right there's like testing
and figuring out what grabs what grabs
the most amount of people uh oh my God
this is scary [ __ ]
you're trying to get us to have kids I
don't want look at this [ __ ] look at
these pacifier looking weirdo I know
they're trying to make a buck too
everyone's trying to make money I know I
know but it is like I guess I just love
living with us like this little Spirit
Angel who doesn't know who Trump is it's
innocent yeah it is just like so special
and she loves you know she just always
wants to be with me and she thinks I'm
so cool and she's just like you know we
have fun together and I I just that's
great yeah yeah I'm a lot of steps away
from this right now but Mark you're
close ah now the French kissing thing
words man I hate to tell your kid isn't
only fans
but well that must be like an older boy
at her school right It's gotta be maybe
thing creeps me out too though I don't
like these like there's some guy who's
like I'm a child distraction actor
that's what I did yeah I distract
children that's my job I mean it's
harrowing and and yes I don't want my
kids face up there and I don't know if
this is true but I heard someone saying
that on some of these videos of kids
you'll see like a Time code in the
comments and if you go to the time code
it's like where the kid shows their
underwear or something so it's just like
everybody like we're all it's it's just
like we have to fight against every
pedophile in the world is on the
internet like why did you want your kid
on the internet Jesus we'll find a way
to make anything sexual and creepy
um I'm sorry I didn't mean to go so no
no we have a big pedophile anyway you
guys should really have a child and get
my book get the book uh unless you're a
pedo you don't deserve her children if
you're a pita now I've been drinking do
pedophiles have kids I doubt it I mean
it's you know it's good
that is a good question though Mark I'm
curious
to fly it's an honest question
said I'm just saying I mean it's just in
the house you don't have to go to a
playground Mark I'm just I'm I'm crazy
snooty pedophiles are like I'll [ __ ] a
kid but not my kid I'm sure there is
that yeah
these are the things I think we're
losing all of our listeners
so bring Al Franken back
that's a bad idea oh yeah I brought a
pedophile around him and he froze he did
not like me or me yeah us I bet he was
thinking you guys were cool and he
wanted you to think he was cool no we
didn't I don't think he liked us
sweet man who's 71. he did not care for
us at all he's 70 really he looked good
he is a good he looks good so I heard
that like actresses are all taking
um diabetes medication to stay skinny is
that right I've heard like three
different people tell me that who's
taking the diabetes I'm not gonna say it
Calista Flocka
but I wonder if like 70 year olds are
doing something too right like some kind
of you know like what was the thing HGH
like yeah maybe he's on something like
that ah he is in politics they know all
about that [ __ ] possibly interesting I
heard the amount of uh female comedians
doing Botox blew my mind I was shocked
wait you didn't know that women did
Botox I didn't know I thought you did it
maybe when you were you know 48
right is it you should not by the way if
you're 20 and you're listening to this
podcast you should not get BOTOX when
you're 20. you get it what age
I don't know when you because I used to
hate that Kardashian lip like that puff
puff around their mouth but if you look
at what the opposite of that is like a
little crinkle here yeah it's like it's
not bad I don't mind a crinkle that's
natural you know but um I I guess I
don't know I I just whatever you do
don't get your lips done and honestly
men shouldn't do anything have you seen
Perry Farrell I don't know that is you
guys don't know who parrot from Jane's
Addiction
oh no well any man
that's like when you get your eyes done
you know when you get looks like he runs
a haunted toy store that's crazy
surgery does not look good on men no
gay men maybe is he getting away with it
he's not gay I don't know I don't think
he's gay maybe he is but see how cute he
was he was a hunk
yeah yeah it's the eyes the eyes are bad
to do you don't want to get your lips
done it's like a picture that you just
keep drawing you know they're like oh
yeah a little more a little more but if
you actually step back and look at it
you're like oh I did too much I think
that's the thing with plastic surgery
they just keep going I know any guys who
have done that he doesn't look bad there
wait did um so Al Franken didn't have
plastic surgery no no no but he looked
good he looked great I mean he's got a
full head of hair and he's hanging in
there he looked really good the way he
he said huh after everything we're
focusing too much on Frankie here you
can cut this out all right keep it give
the people what they want he doesn't
know what podcasts are even though he
has one but yeah nice guy nice guy sweet
kid my best friend all right hey hey
folks when going through your daily
checklist make sure hydration stays on
the top of the list liquid IV is easy
the only easy way to stay hydrated get
five essential vitamins and hydrate two
times faster than with water alone with
just one stick of liquid IV whether
you're prepping for the day or a long
haul flight or on vacation liquid IV is
essential addition to your routine all
kinds of good flavors I like pina colada
that's my fave I got a big Shelf full of
liquid IV I got all the flavors a ton of
bags of it lemon lime I love very good
grapes sometimes I pretend I'm drinking
yummy pee nice all right Kelly all right
use Liquid Ivy first thing in the
morning for a workout when you feel run
down or after a long night a bodega cat
why not Hydrate with a single serving
packet and it helps you hydrate on the
go big fan I use it we drink a lot
obviously the booze will kill you
recharge replenish reinvigorate with
liquid IV it contains five essential
vitamins B3 B5 B6 B12 and vitamin C it
contains three times the electrolytes is
a traditional sports drink made with
premium ingredients gluten-free Dairy
and soy free
it uses cellular transport technology
designed to enhance rapid absorption of
water and other key ingredients in the
bloodstream tell them how grab your
liquid IV in bulk nationwide at Costco
or you can get 20 when you go to liquid
iv.com and use code drunk at checkout
that's 20 anything you order when you
shop better hydration today using promo
code drunk at liquid iv.com nice hey
folks this episode is sponsored by
betterhelp look Adidas dropped Kanye so
to Balenciaga a better help should pick
up Kanye he needs it if life came with a
user manual things would be easy for
everyone but it isn't so when it's not
working for you it's normal to feel
stuck navigating a career change a new
relationship or beginning a parent
becoming a parent can make you feel
uncertain therapists are trained to help
you learn productive coping skills which
makes therapy the closest thing you'll
get to a user manual for you we all go
to therapy we all go to the same guy
love him love him it's a game changer
you got me in I'm hooked he knows me too
well I know we were talking the other
day about a toxic woman and he goes uh
you're not done with her I was like yes
I am because I know how you are you love
it I'm like I was like [ __ ] you Alan man
he's good oh yeah he is good better help
us online there but over his video phone
and chat therapy sessions you can choose
to to not see anyone on camera if that
makes you feel better tell them how to
do it fatty as the world's largest
therapy service better help has matched
three million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists available
100 online plus it's affordable just
fill out a brief questionnaire to match
with a therapist if things aren't
clicking you can easily switch back to a
new therapist anytime it couldn't be
simpler no waiting rooms no traffic no
endless searching for the right
therapist learn more and save 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com drunk
that's better
help.com slash drunk hey folks we might
be drunk is brought to you by Factor if
you can't stand the heat get out of the
kitchen factor is here to give you
delicious healthy meals that are ready
in minutes with factors spend less time
in the kitchen more fun in the sun it's
fresh never Frozen prepared super good
delicious you don't believe and they're
good for you with 30 meals offered each
week you'll never be bored with your
meal plans each meal arrives
pre-prepared and ready to eat in two
minutes that's faster than getting a
pizza
look at all they got they got vegan
veggie meals low calorie options juices
smoothies energy bites plant-based bars
extra protein and veggie size to every
meal they sent me a bunch they were
great it's really good it's really good
I ate one every day I'd give them to the
lady she's a food snob she liked it
those smoothies are incredible yeah nice
is having the house coconut milk
so good so I had to go dot
factor75.com drunk 60. that's code
drunk60 at go dot
factor75.com
drunk60 to get 60 off your first box
it's good I really liked it I mean my
freezer just to pearly you never know
when you want a quick two minute uh heat
up you know healthy eating Made Easy
yeah
all right we might be drunk is also
brought to you by Lucy nicotine gum
everybody who tries to quit smoking it's
hard there's books about it there's
lectures there's TED Talks there's
hypnotists all this stuff but quitting
smoke is the hardest thing you'd ever do
but not with Lucy baby Lucy was founded
by Caltech scientists former smokers who
want to help other people quit they set
out to create a better and cleaner
nicotine alternative it took three years
of research but they made Lucy a
nicotine gum that actually tastes good
comes at Wintergreen cinnamon
pomegranate and if you don't like gum
they got lozenges baby citrus mint or
cherry ice
I like the Citrus Goes Down Easy yeah oh
yeah I used to chew this just for a
little jolt each has four milligrams of
nicotine when you're craving a smoke you
need a little something to satisfy that
habit get your fix Lucy's got you baby
subscribe monthly too and they'll send
it right to your house tell them how
sloppy jalopy they're supporting this
show so go to go God [ __ ] damn it
we're not even drinking yet there's the
poor I think we're better with the
alcohol maybe it loosens us up a little
bit they're supporting the show so go
support them get 20 off all products
including gum or lozenges at lucy.co
with code drunk that's 20 off lucy.co
and use promo code drunk at checkout and
here's the part the lawyers make us say
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical but what is it these
days am I right good point no duh get 20
off at lucy.co with code drunk
yeah he's Nicole he's a new co-host how
did you two get together are you just
like both we've known each other
hilarious comedians years and years of
open mics the whole thing no Mark
forever and uh and then we during the
pandemic we try we tried this on Zoom it
was that thing where we talked about the
the spirit of the Pod was like the end
of the night we were like I have one
more drink right it turns into you know
5 a.m 6 a.m we're [ __ ] wasted and it
turned into that we tried it on zoom
we're like we'll have like a cocktail on
zoom and do a podcast and it was really
fun yeah and it turned into a thing you
know that's the one thing I will say
about having a kid that that feeling you
have when you're younger where you're
like let's keep the party going you know
like that one where you're like okay I
could go to bed now but if I like smoked
three more cigarettes and like smoked
some pot and then then you have another
drink and then you're kind of up till
three or four like that instinct you
kind of have to like squash that as an
adult you don't have to but as a parent
I find because then you have to get up
at seven
thank you I'm away from my family this
week yeah especially if you don't if you
don't squash you into fighting people in
a 7-Eleven
no I know what you mean but think about
being a kid what was the most fun you
ever had it's when you had a friend's
house you're sleeping over and you pour
an all-nighter watching movies eating
like junk food oh yeah that's the best
night you'll ever have as a kid the best
staying up all night usually let me
let's watch a [ __ ] movie yeah sleepy
sleep in my friend's place and we're
just we're like sixth grade just chain
smoking cigarettes watching a bootleg
Fight Club you're chain smoking in maybe
seventh grade love it really we're bad
kids
[Laughter]
did your mom know you were smoking no of
course not until one day smell it well
we were at a friend's house but I
remember yeah my mom found them once and
was really pissed at me I blamed her I
smoke cause of you she's like why I
don't smoke I was like I don't know yeah
I don't know if Ted hit me once and I
said I'm telling social services and he
was like where the [ __ ] you learned that
that was my big move yeah my the other
day my daughter she like she kind of hit
me and I was like oh I was like ow or I
said don't do that and I just brushed
her arm away and she started screaming
police whoa
and she's clearly like playing but also
like she must have heard that on the
playground because their school's kind
of mixed so there's some older boys
there and stuff but she was like police
police I think she yeah she was like my
mom she
and I was like oh that was you like I
you hurt me and I said I moved your hand
so it's pretty smart
that's like diabolical she Twisted it oh
no yikes and then somebody comes over I
heard police she said defund
yeah it's so hard I'm trying to get over
the idea that I every decision I you
know like I want to make the perfect
decision of course in everything I know
as Dr Drew would say just the fact that
you're worried about that is already a
good sign he would say that yeah that's
what he always said on Loveline back in
the day so as long as there is like the
Instinct of love and trying to figure
yeah like somebody would call and go I'm
worried about my daughter a word about
my son he would go just the fact that
you're trying to fix this problem and
worried about it is means you're a good
parent yeah being present it seems like
such a big part of that right I know and
like the whole so much about having a
little kid is like let's wrap it up you
know like every every activity it's just
like so do you want to play pirate ship
you know and then like you can't look at
your phone and like Bonnie McFarland
told me she used to set a timer to like
not look at her phone when she was with
her kid and like you know just and that
whole time she has to listen to Rich
Voss that's very hard
but you know we love Rich by the way
yeah and I love Bonnie yeah
Bonnie on here by the way I love Bonnie
she is so funny I mentioned her in my
book so dry and so she's hilarious and
she has
that was the last she has a great book
out too that Anthony Bourdain did the
forward to so whoa and a great
documentary Women aren't funny but she
also
um
she has a really great relationship with
her kid like her kid really loves her
and they just seem like you know like
that's kind of how you watch my kids
gonna hate me but well she did start
saying this thing lately Laura she's
like Mom don't say don't tell people
things I say
because Jesus I know and I'm just like
okay so I was like I guess I can't put
this material into a special that she
can watch when she's 12. yeah
it's gonna live right if I put it on
tape yeah of course and then you know I
think someone's like suing their parents
right now for like putting them on
Instagram people are like very into
their rights which I understand you know
yeah well then you should actually give
all the money back from when you raise
them
good point yeah I won't joke about you
goodbye college fund yeah raise yourself
[ __ ] I didn't pay I to pay for
my own College that's why I went to City
University
I went to Hunter College but it was a
good education yeah 1200 a semester wow
what was it like being a college kid in
Midtown Manhattan it was pretty awful
really I mean it was just like being
poor yeah yeah I really I really didn't
like my time in New York so it is always
nice to come back here and be able to
afford a cab that is helpful yeah there
was a lot of like buses and Subways and
rats that's the problem with New York
too like anytime where the rats are like
like in the summer I would see a rat
every day
I know you guys do too right look more
you got to learn to live with the rats
is that what it is you learn to live
with them I I can't look I'm gonna need
a New Yorker I love New York I I can't
defend certain elements of the city you
just have I was trying to get my ex to
live here and it's like you know we'd be
walking around and she'd be like this is
just like bad and I'd be like yeah
yeah it's bad but it's like it's true
New Yorker but you know look the uh
there's gonna be rats out sometimes
you'll see them [ __ ] that's fun no
you'll see a homeless Cocker oh yeah
that's a good thing to see because
you're like all right they're not
worried about me yeah they're just
[ __ ] each other and the prize yeah
you'll see a homeless [ __ ] every once in
a while but here's what we have at La
doesn't Pizza is slightly uh open later
so we got our stuff too yeah here here
it is getting less but the things no New
York has got a lot of problems right now
but I do think some of the crime stuff
is being blown out of proportion by the
media I think they they like to create
fear so same with LA everyone's saying
it's like dangerous to be in La too so I
think it's it's the same thing that
those people are doing with cocoa melon
they're like trying to figure out what
will not avert anyone's eyes from the
story
I'll hear from people and they're like I
hear the crimes getting pretty bad in in
New York City and I'm like you live in
downtown Indianapolis uh what do you
think this is a [ __ ] Whitehaven
Community like right [ __ ] in urban areas
there's always going to be crime they're
densely populated New York there is a
there is crime occasionally I'm not
gonna like sugarcoat it no there is yeah
but
I don't think it's as bad as people are
letting you lead you to believe it's all
there's millions of people here so
there's always crime but now it's being
kind of a show I won't say this I saw a
guy shooting up on the [ __ ] corner
here
I saw a guy shooting heroin into his
hand ah as I'm [ __ ] walking in here
so that's not a crime
it is a crime it's a crime but it's not
a crime against another person yeah hurt
yourself people are gonna start getting
pissed yeah the drug use is up I will
say a lot of needles a lot of needles oh
really I took one before your wedding
buddy huh stop and I got IV drip oh good
for you
it's great I was hungover as [ __ ] cause
I ended up at a gas station with stuff
eating fried food and uh an Ari and we
we end up in the hotel lobby and then I
was so [ __ ] up uh wait is this the
wedding when you did our podcast you're
on your way to it oh that was Dana
Gould's wedding oh right right that was
uh that was a great time too but we uh
this is a week ago and we were so
[ __ ] we had we had a funny IV drip
guy oh really he was calling us he was
calling us gay it was [ __ ] God he was
like I'm gonna put some gay porn in this
IV drip and we're like we don't know
what that means but it doesn't really
work but stops like throw it in there
bud how did you feel after the needle
great I mean it really doesn't it helps
it does oh yeah it's an absurd way do
you guys do this a lot
yeah that's true and what is he what do
you what is it what does it do is it
like is it just really promises you no
little uh hydration but what's the thing
Zofran so that kills nausea oh I didn't
know about that yeah so they're putting
a lot of vitamins in there and and it's
just saline it just it hydrates you and
uh you're back you're like all right
click again could you get that from
pounding water it won't it just won't
get to you no no way that's why you
usually need to sleep it off this is
like right in your vein so you're like
oh I'm back I mean you literally I'm so
I felt so ill yeah and I put it in me
and I like I could drink exactly really
yeah I pour a little wine in my bag
there get it right to the vein cake
bread or uh cupcake cupcake
yeah the nutrients is even out it's
actually it's growing on me now that I
know it's more expensive I'm really
learning to enjoy it I like white wine
yeah red wine red wine can really give
you a headache and so I'm just kind of
like over that same I can't I can't do
it with the kid no it's so hard to stay
healthy being a comedian because like
it's the only job where someone asks you
like four times if you want to drink
it's like if you're like no I'm not
drinking tonight and then someone else
comes in they're like hey can we get you
something no I'm good and then by the
time the third waiter comes in you're
like okay fine all right fine I'll get
drunk oh I know and I'll send shots on
stage I'm like they don't do that at
Broadway you know it's uh it's just us
right or theater it would be if you saw
a theater actor drinking before they
went on stage and be like that guy
probably has a problem exactly wouldn't
you think that yeah I mean it's just
like so it's hard to shut down after the
show too sometimes like I'll have at
least one or two because you're just
after take the edge out it's hard not to
yeah well you probably do really well on
stage sometimes I'm like I'm glad that's
over you know what it is my problem is
you guys maybe you can help me because
you're both Master comedians
will kill
and like I never end strong it's like
it's almost like against my principles
like it feels very like
sports like I'm gonna Crush I'm gonna
destroy like I used to oh I used to open
for a John caparula remember him oh yeah
funny guy he's very funny but he would
get a standing ovation every night and
it would be like at the exact same spot
and I'm like what is how many new hours
was he putting out though I don't know
so I mean I heard he repeated a lot of
stuff I think he's very funny
I think when you're playing hits you're
gonna Crush harder and like some Comics
like to do that but I think if you're
constantly trying to do new stuff you're
gonna have dips and that's just part of
the yeah but but but I will say bomb
last night it's part of you did sure I
was doing new [ __ ] it sucks you got to
work it out well I I did this one person
show a while ago and I hired this tap
dancing troupe of kids and their teacher
to like come in and do a do a number and
they would do this thing and they're
like okay well if we go like this and
then to the side and then do the shuffle
then we'll get then we'll get a standing
over here then we'll get the Applause
break so they kind of knew physically
what what people needed to hear yeah to
like then have everyone erupt and so it
was like this um form you know right
right I'm always like I wonder if
there's something why don't you say
you're crushing in the beginning why
don't you just move that material to the
end yeah is it an energy thing or what
is it are you doing newer [ __ ] at the
end it's it's almost like I just I just
just done I think they can feel that
they can feel like she wants to go if
you want to go they want to go I I have
I don't know I don't know what it is I
guess it's just this idea of making
people like
[Music]
the closer is always the hardest to
write but you're right
opening thing that's killing and then
try to put that at the end I'm like I'm
like 23 years into comments
but it's like I enjoy it so much till
the end interesting I don't know why
that is that's you got to listen to the
said maybe it's the order or something
but also is what Mark said maybe it's
the enthusiasm maybe you're checking out
maybe you're thinking about getting home
possibly but I do yes I do think that I
I would love to feel that sort of
Crescendo that feeling where I needed to
have a couple drinks to come down
like Sam he's like in his hotel room
like all wired and so wired I don't
sleep it's surprised I don't either it's
uh you don't sleep I'm so bad with sleep
yeah I'm on pills
to sleep well Moshe too He's like We
you're on pills to sleep yeah Seroquel
you should not be taking it I know are
there bad it's horrible and it doesn't
work that well either what are you doing
that's very I can't sleep I can't sleep
have you tried weed like like not doing
that too I'm doing the uh the Edibles or
whatever the gummies yeah but don't
don't take the ones that like acted no
no no no no and melatonin so for the
word activate for weed it's been
activated well that's how I feel when I
smoke weed because I smoke like the more
strong you know yeah you smoke a lot
um yeah that's all right you're very
pleasing energy your energy is like very
uh you're chill you're like an easy yes
well I remember asking a lot well I
asked my therapist I was like should I
not smoke pot and he's like I think it
kind of works with your personality I
mean I haven't smoked today but
um yes I'm pretty chill I definitely
didn't used to be really well I was like
extremely ambitious
um I was just like I wanted to like you
know I thought I should get into
Juilliard like I was just like I was
just like I had my eye and then I like
when I pivoted to Comedy I was just like
I would work so hard I remember Ari at
the time he was reach out my Ari Shapiro
yeah he was just such a hard worker and
he really inspired me and he would like
he had this like sign on his hat in his
in his bedroom that said you're you're
not good till you bomb 50 times Bobby
Lee and then he had like the numbers and
then he would cross out every time he
bombed and he was like on 20. and he was
trying to get to 30. he's at 4 000 now
you beat me to it
but I remember I kept a little full I
had like a little
um you know like a calendar and I would
like make sure I counted every you know
I was trying to like beat my record and
make sure I went up like 10 times a week
or this I would like take a bus to an
ice cream shop and like do a 5 p.m show
then a 7 P.M show then a 9 p.m show and
I was just like so ambitious for it for
whatever it was you know and I think
that you have to be in the beginning
that's the reason I guess what I'm
saying is like having a kid just puts it
into perspective a little bit sure and I
just feel like my time is more valuable
and and you know I just don't have the
energy to close strong
what that is an extra incentive I mean
you're you're thinking about getting
home to a kid that's not
an issue that we have but I also know
comedians who had kids and are like oh
[ __ ] I gotta I gotta step it up now and
they're gonna say I gotta stretch I'm
doing another hour
no that's how you know a guy just had a
baby because like all of a sudden he
puts out his tour schedule and he's in
like a different city every night just
gone all right yeah I don't want to be
there but I do think you're right Sam
like really challenging yourself to do
new stuff is is hard like I followed
Sarah Silverman the other night and she
was kind of like she had like a notebook
and she was kind of going through all
this stuff and you know the crowd was
like whatever and then I went up and I
was like I'm gonna kill you know and
it's like because Sarah was always
someone I looked up to and I was like
okay you know and then I I got off stage
and I was like wow I can't believe I'm
doing I I was so strong out there and I
was like wait Sarah was like making
herself do all new materials you know
and like I'm like throwing out the hits
and like doing crowd you know like
killing it and it's like you have to be
able to balance and make yourself elf
maybe not when you're headlining on the
road on your like tour whatever but you
know just being able to go up there and
force you because you do have to bomb a
little bit like you don't know if this
thing's gonna be funny and when you're
at Sarah's level like where are you
gonna try your new stuff you're not like
going to like a cafe right right
and by the way she was killing but like
you know she they were definitely
laughing but it was like she was clearly
trying new stuff and it's like I forget
to do that sometimes but there's a
middle ground you can do your a [ __ ]
then try the new then go back to the a
then try the new and and then you're
golden I wish we had like a workshop and
we could all like let's do it do you
have a bit you're working on
um because I want to throw one out too
after you guys you go first I'll go
first don't tell me there's something
here it did not hit the other night I
think there's something here all right
um I had a girl over and uh we we hooked
up I came pretty quickly so I felt
guilty I was like let me go down on you
I want to make sure after you come
inside her then you go in a condom oh
okay okay yeah
well I I was think I forgot people use
condoms yeah you're still doing that
still come on I'll be doing it till I'm
[ __ ] married all right uh yeah so I
uh so you came quick you went down on
her yeah and I'm down there for a while
and I've got you know I've got a bad
neck I'm counting the [ __ ] minutes
so yeah I'm counting but it was a good
20 minutes for sure you know it's a
while love to smell that stubble
and then uh and then finally she just
goes uh she goes okay I came and I was
like that's it you think she was lying I
think she was so I said like did you
really come and she goes yeah and I was
like would you tell me if you were lying
to me and she goes uh yeah I I came and
I was like all right I'm like you
promised you tell me I tell you and then
we're hanging out watching a movie and
she's like uh you know it's a long drive
for me home uh do you mind if I spend
the night I was like no spend the night
and she goes uh are you sure that's okay
with you and I was like of course she
goes would you tell me if you were lying
and I was like
sorry I didn't make you come
is that something there I think there's
something there yeah because it just
hits me there is this yeah I like that
I'm trying to think of a way to make it
more clear to the audience yeah there's
a step is missing yeah I'm so I'm so
lost in the Dynamics of like this like
she's has to ask you to spend the night
like it's all making me like she she
lied to him and now no no no you have to
lie to her right
um but that's cool that's clearly not
clear in the bed maybe there's got to be
some word I guess it's like something in
between like if you say uh
ah I'm trying to think um
maybe it's the same thing you guys say
to each other like yeah babe it's hard
when you don't know the person
you said a little more sarcasm of course
you can of course I did of course I came
yeah like if she says something about
the not about coming and then you say
the same thing later that she said just
so they really hits home with you that's
what I said I said she goes are you sure
she goes yeah and she's the same thing
to me she goes are you sure but I think
you need something more more uh
accentuated than are you sure like you
tell me if you didn't yeah like
something like that just so it really
hits home because you know the audience
they're idiots
that was sexy oh yeah I'm trying to feel
the dead air that was hot bro
can we cut in your burp after my [ __ ]
bomb of a joke I can go if you're
looking
I think this okay
it's a big joke that has been bombing
funny
let's hear it okay I was saying like um
you know it's it's kind of nice getting
older because now I feel like I'm like
no longer a rapist first choice
and so I can kind of like relax a little
bit but all the women in the front you
know like the hot women like then I
tried to do that with a with a woman in
the front I'm like but you're doing like
good work man like I'm here for you
you're in the front lines right but I
think it's like do the women laugh or
are they freaked out I think I think I
don't do rape jokes no no no no no no
that's so funny first off it's a funny
joke I think it needs one more line to
really because that jokes that always
like push people a second I think they
need one like tag I think that's really
funny but I think I would say something
like I'm no longer a rapist First Choice
you know now you know I used to I used
to walk quickly home now I you know when
I take my time yeah I linger a little
bit I throw in my ear my earpods it'll
be fine what about someone who's like
one out of three women are sexually
abused it's like I feel like now we have
all of these like statistics and numbers
like right pressing down upon us and
it's like I don't want to ever be a part
of the problem that makes someone
uncomfortable you've been in La too long
right there holy [ __ ] I think you can
say that up top be like man this
Statistics one in three women oh my God
that's why I feel good now because I'm
obviously the second choice or something
like that see what you're saying soften
it a little bit Yeah but let me tell you
something you take that to the Midwest
that joke's killing those things oh yeah
that's like crowds that are [ __ ] like
are we part of the problem if we laugh
you know what I mean where it's like
it's a joke you clearly I think are you
condoning sexual assault of course not
are you mocking victims no you're this
is a self-deprecating joke well it's
actually making me it's actually because
I I remember like as a woman you walk
through society and you're like always
on edge you're like who's going to
assault me who is going to bother me I
mean you could you could you could what
if you opened it with that that's funny
they do is and then that's why I love
getting older because I'm no longer oh
that's good so just a little bit of
context yeah yeah I think a rape joke
coming out of nowhere people are like
what but if you build it up a little bit
I hear what Mark's saying and then one
more line like you know something like I
can take my time I can you know right it
sucked up at the perks I'll stop and
like adjust my my uh yeah yeah there you
go I'll like uh try to but then it's
like I'm trying to woo them I mean come
on no that's funny that's funny I mean
we're doing comedy here I feel like we
didn't help you at all Sam though I I'm
gonna come up with a there's a wording
that she says I'm like so Jarred by like
coming like all of the the I'm like
putting myself in this world of like
huge
trying to make this girl come and like
I'm just like uh I don't know I feel
it's I was trying it's very
it's vulgar Ah that's not like a Rapture
well I think it was also something funny
about just like 20 minutes of me going
down there and her just going I came I'm
like it's like the end of an indie film
or something you're like I guess that's
the ending right that is how indie films
ends Lost in Translation that's a funny
all right I'll throw that in there the
credits just rolled I don't know right
even if you're going she's like I came
and you're like did you come she's like
oh yeah that was great or that was good
or something and then she's like should
I stay over and you're like oh yeah
that's a good idea please oh yeah
because you don't want her to stay
either maybe joke that wasn't clearly
that wasn't that was not clear it's all
we see they help me it's all finished
all right what uh what what do you got
Mark all right well mine's mine sucks
mine's weird but uh mine sucked in was
weird too okay well mine we all suck all
right well that's what that's what new
joke that's supposed to be new and uh
We're Not Afraid yes putting ourselves
on the line I love honorable okay
they've watched us bomb so many times
mostly in the Al Franken episode but
yikes they've watched us bomb so many
bad ideas it's been a while we haven't
done enough bits on here I agree and we
should do more wrecks and peeves make
sure we always get those in there but
true give me give me a bit okay so I saw
a headline that said uh
transgender inmate impregnates female
prisoner and I thought holy [ __ ] where's
that porn you know like it's it's a news
headline but it feels like I've been
watching porn my whole life and it's
always elaborate you know these these
ridiculous videos where like that would
never happen come on that's silly but
now I feel like I watch the news and I'm
like this is insane like I feel like
when I'm an adult and I have kids I'm
gonna go turn the news off put some porn
on like porn has gotten so quaint now
it's like teacher has sex with student
I'm like that's nice you know funny I
like that porn has gotten quaint porn
compared to the news the news is like
Jesus you know like Jewish space laser
kids in cages mass shooting you know
it's insane it's also funny that like
teacher [ __ ] student is just the news
too it's like it's all it's so connected
right right that's true Mark that's
definitely something there's something
there there's something there like
telling the kid to turn the news off
what's the headline again
transgender inmate impregnates female
prisoner and you're like that feels like
a porn it's like a prison
transporn you know and I'm like that's
just a news story so the news has gotten
so nutty that I'm like
I like the idea that that like all of
the school shootings and all of the you
know everything that's that's all the
violence yeah and you know you you the
porn is quaint I think okay that that's
the the meat of it I think so all right
maybe I'm thinking in a porn category
don't make it about trans people no I'm
not that was just the headline that
grabbed my eye on uh you know it's kind
of hot impregnates female prisoner I'm
like picturing them in a prison you know
it feels like a porn
tired it's not really impregnate porn is
there
that's true don't people I used to date
a guy I guess it's cream pie I guess she
always wanted to like [ __ ] a pregnant
woman or he always thought it was hot
like there was someone in the grocery
store you would like that's a kid a
pregnant woman that is a category why
it's hot I don't know because I know
guys into pregnant women yeah but why
why is that why are you because they're
such a feminine that such a that's a
woman big or I don't know like uh
voluptuous maybe
being a man must be exhausting are you
right are you watching The Vow like it's
just like people are so important men
are so horny yeah yeah this guy Keith
Ranieri he's like got a cult but he's
just like every person who comes in the
cult he's like no you gotta suck my dick
and it's just like the and the girl was
like I knew that every time we were
alone it was my you know I had to
immediately start sucking his dick it's
like wow but I think some guys they just
they need to start a cult
yeah you said being a guy sounds exotic
Mike that sounds pretty restful yeah I
don't know wait how many times a day
would you guys like your dick sucked
ideally there wasn't like a weird
weirdness to it it's like Muslims with
praying I think five I don't know I'm
joking I'd be good with one I think
because one a day one is good one you
don't want to you want to abuse it I
think if you do it too much it's not
going to be special anymore you know so
one a day and then what about jerk off
is that like if you don't get the dick
sucked once a day are you probably
trying to jerk off once a day yeah yeah
I'd probably jack off once a day okay
two on the road because you got that
extra time you got the extra time and
you know you want to just that sweet
internet access yeah exactly I want to
be clear-headed for the show too and
does does does jacking off help you be
clear-headed it helps me from making a
bad decision that's what I was getting
at then you don't [ __ ] the the fans or
the ones Well yeah if I rub what I
remember I was talking to a comic one
she was married now and he was like how
do you not cheat on the road I was like
might just jack off a lot it helps he
was like yo that's [ __ ] genius that
never that never occurred to you to just
jack up whoa that was Adam Levine
he didn't take my advice
um wait he's the guy who just um he was
he like dming the boys he's got a
Victoria's Secret model wife I believe
well but did you know what he did he he
dm'd his the girl he was cheating on his
Victoria's Secret model wife with and
asked her they used to have they were
they were [ __ ] then they stopped then
he asked her do you mind if my wife is
pregnant do you mind if we name the kid
after you oh that was because he liked
the name Sumner Sumner damn and so they
named he was [ __ ] something to
Redstone that's crazy who's that looks
like the head of Icon right but it's
like 95. I'll pull up a picture of him
the joke works with a picture of the guy
oh okay that's even better but that's
pretty [ __ ] up
yeah yeah well that's a quite a move man
if we had this picture during that joke
I said it would have been it would have
been pretty fun damn we had a time
machine look at that guy I'm just saying
it's classic I wonder who he dates that
guy makes Orville redboxer look handsome
he had a [ __ ] he had a young ass wife
obviously I mean I'm trying to think
like oh there you go there she goes you
just I don't know what work he had done
but it like suckled the face and the
neck he's actually taking diabetes
medicine yeah look at that [ __ ] imagine
[ __ ] him I was thinking the other day
like I don't like big tits necessarily
he's got them
but in a woman like if you don't have
big tits you pretty much can't be an
A-list actress marry a billionaire those
are true they all they all want you
could be an Alicia what A-list actress
has a a boobs uh I don't know Matt look
it up Selma Blair
I don't know if she's A-list
Claire Danes Claire Danes might have
small boobs okay hot actors with small
tits uh Keira Knightley Natalie Portman
boom okay all right as your search
history your search history is
not have small tits she's just uh oh
these are just like those are those
ideas does not have small tits okay
look at that that's Keira Knightley all
right her I believe Miley Cyrus I mean
that's just a picture of her as a child
she has small tits
okay well you know marrying a
billionaire Marion but you might have us
there okay all right oh Carrie Russell
she was pretty but those are not that's
that's a bra
she's probably still really hot probably
oh yeah Gwyneth Paltrow I like a small
boob oh Kate Hudson's got real small
ones small tits definitely age better
yeah big tits for sure but you know
small boobs my all the models have small
boobs
just snapping
the agreeance snap he's pretend he's in
[ __ ] West Side Story right now just
snapping out of nowhere
you guys haven't been talking to the
bartender enough address him as the
beard you please yes the beer Jew it's a
long story okay Kanye named him I'm not
at all well there's the Bear Jew in in
uh glorious fast and he's a big Burly
man so we just called him the the beer
Jew okay well I really appreciate you
going to all this effort for our look at
him there's Vibe Eli Roth he's a hunk
huh
you like Jewish men no no that's who
we're basing him on
I didn't see that movie he beats up
Nazis well we yeah there was something
else I was going to ask you about now I
[ __ ] lost it you wrote a book you're
uh are you you're not on the road no I
haven't tour but oh it's over okay what
what about uh peeves do you have any
peeves
oh yeah good question
um the Booth's going to my head we've
been drinking all day Mark and I Franken
I have a recommendation please okay
three words ooh movie it's a movie oh
okay we're doing charades
triangle of sadness I hear it's great I
don't know this it was so good pull it
up it was definitely what I kind of
movie like very like class commentary
but comedy I mean that's not a great
picture
um I've heard the movies it was so good
and it was just it just reminded me what
I it did you ever see Force Major yes
same director writer about the guy who
like there's a snowstorm coming and then
instead of saving his family he grabs a
cell phone right they remade it wasn't
that good but great social commentary
um really amazing funny I loved it all
right and I I kind of hate everything
yeah yeah dude are you a hater
for sure
I just did Drew Barrymore and like she's
one of those people who says like she's
just like she can't say anything yeah
and so it's like female Jimmy Fallon
kinda as a comedian it is so hard to
like because everything I want to say is
dark you know and it's just like to get
out of that like it it is refreshing
being around people like that but um I I
do I I am so drawn to the darkness
I think most comedians are you know and
I think that
you know it's it's just uh why is it
only 69 that was such a good movie I
don't believe this stuff no that should
there's nothing funny about like wasn't
this great I mean that's literally why
we do peeves but they're not trying to
be funny people aren't that's what it is
they're just like trying to do something
but that's why we're like as Comics
we're drawn to like complaints
complaining therapeutic complaining's
funny as long as you and we have to be
very conscious while we're complaining
to not be a drain because there's
nothing [ __ ] worse than being
cornered by a person at a party who's
just a drain yes I read that the royal
family that their motto in life is never
complain never explain
whoa and I was like whoa if you could do
that that would be so epic you might
become Royal yeah yeah or divorced my uh
my lady would hate that she complains a
lot well we've been married for four
days I know it's terrifying but we we
both complain and we and she's always
like I don't know what you mean you got
to talk to me because I'm a psycho who
bottles everything up and she's a normal
person who's like no let's talk about it
I'm like talk about it no we'll just go
through life being miserable so no you
gotta talk about you got to talk about
it so she's getting me through it I
never went on a vacation until I met her
when you it makes me you know it's like
oh yeah there you go like speaking in I
statements this kind of helps instead of
like accusing accusing right right I
feel like Scripps help me too
communicate sometimes like when I was
navigating my relationship with mosha
sometimes I would be like I'll just call
you and we'll have this talk and I would
have like bullet points you know
sometimes you just have to like get the
right script that's like not accusatory
not gonna set them off you know it's
like there's a way to
all right sophisticatedly manipulate
people
I like to be your next book yeah
sophisticatedly manipulate this I'm
gonna see because I'm worried about
movies
it's supposed to be really good too
what's that banshees what's it called
again pulled up a lot of good horror out
now and I'm not a huge horror of course
exactly too I haven't seen this the
Banshees of issue yeah it's Martin
McDonough who did like in Bruges oh it's
like a like a sequel I've seen his he
had a play recently that I see he's
awesome he's so good yeah so I'll watch
that you're gonna see that we're gonna
see triangle of sadness I like the new
Neil Brennan special I saw that in
Montreal it was amazing very funny hey
he he ended on something serious yeah
that was weird but uh the jokes were
great now we love new we'll have them
all yeah Neil's coming on soon we love
Neo uh check out his special I got a few
for you hit me people posting photos on
like social media and just the caption
being like so this happened yeah we know
that's the [ __ ] picture it happened
we saw no no one's commenting I'm
confused we know what [ __ ] happened
right for some reason that bugs me I'm
with you what about when people are like
something really Big's about to happen
I'm posting it Wednesday big
announcement you guys like that no
because it's never big it's never good
yes
something Big's coming next day I'm
getting divorced uh things are bad for
me yeah it is bad that's pretty
Big's happening something bad's coming
another I got another P for you not
every [ __ ] murderer deserves a true
crime on Netflix
scratch it too like sometimes I'm
watching something I'm like why are
there six episodes of this oh my God the
bodybuilding woman Sally I watched that
I watched it I [ __ ] hated this woman
before I knew she was a murderer nah she
was a little slow This Woman's not
interesting and then does she murdered
her husband I'm like still not
interesting so you should do this bit
instead of the one where the girls
really yeah
I [ __ ] hate it dude yeah that was a
weak one are you boys on Tick Tock I am
I pay a guy to do mine I mean I I've
just been starting to do it speaking of
peeves because oh she is quite something
oh yeah so she's a murderer I'm actually
interested well her husband was abusive
would you let her do squats on your face
yes
now there aren't a lot of how many
female murderers are there no not enough
kidding there's uh there's women who
kill my wife watches all these female
murderer shows they that's how women do
she deserves a pose like she's a
murderer in the [ __ ] poster the
poster is this she was a marine I know
but oh I still deserve the cover of your
murder it looks very heroic right this
is you're not in Rambo too like yeah you
murdered your husband
is that a picture of Dahmer with an
American flag behind him just like this
yeah
is it playing volleyball at the beach
um but yeah yeah well we're done yeah
there's too many murder murder docs
they're scraping the barrel do you have
a recommendation oh
let me see uh I got a million peeves and
now I'm blanking on them well I just had
a wedding so how was your wedding it was
uh it was great it was right in my lady
planned for months and months and we
fought over it and we spent a ton of
money and all that and it turned out
great my my thing if anyone's planning a
wedding was always just get the cheapest
option because really like here's what
well not with the wine but like every
there's so many decisions they're like
do you want white chairs do you want
brown chairs do you want bamboo chairs
and like everything's like an uptick you
know oh yeah when everyone's sitting in
the chairs it doesn't matter ah here
here here you should I wish I could talk
to her she went the exact opposite route
uh I mean it happens and I did it in
some ways but like sure you know I had a
food truck I was just oh look at Ari
drunk Ari on shrooms on the right wait
Mark you were such a cool outfit too
that's red velvet cute look at those
cufflinks baby men ever wear anything
besides a dumb black suit I went for it
other stuff forcing oral sex I was gonna
say this does not no that's post uh no
that was the day yeah you got a gorgeous
wife
we're all surprised she was mail order
it was wasn't cheap yeah there you go
there's singing uh Springsteen that was
[ __ ] well what was your
floor party did you have went to Florida
and with Bert and got after it yeah you
wish I was there be in charge of your
well we didn't let him he took over but
I mean I'm sure you traveled in style we
had a great time yeah that's all I'll
say great great way we buried a few
ladies
I'm just kidding but remember that movie
Very Bad Things oh yeah
that was a big kiss that was a [ __ ]
dark imagine trying to sell that now we
kill a stripper in Vegas and then we all
turn on each other and the lead is
Jeremy Piven
it's based on a true story
um well your wife is gorgeous she I'm
very lucky I loved her I loved her
wedding look yes good luck headband
cleavage you name it
a girl I was talking to one point
grabbed her a headband I'm like crazy ah
you're crazy I did my Norman voice yeah
that'll do it at the end I went marriage
did you make your wedding funny
a little we had Sean Patton do the
officiating and Joe list gave a funny
speech see I had additional Jewish
wedding and Moshe was mad that I was
kind of like we had I had to do a dance
where I dance around him and he was like
oh you kind of made it funny but like
it's so hard to not I know do something
funny you're a Jew you converted right I
did whoa I mean that's a big deal it's
not easy to convert to no that's a lot
of work it's a lot of work and
um now that I have a kid and Christmas
is coming and she's five I'm like oh you
can have Christmas
yeah hey we got the Hanukkah song okay
would you be okay if if if you had a
Christmas tree yeah he's not gonna marry
a Jew let's be honest ah okay that's not
true I might no you guys would Clash two
annoying people going at it
you need a little yin and yang
oh you marry a girl who converts for you
wouldn't that make you feel like a man
yeah
baby you better [ __ ] become a Jew for
me you know what your real Power movie
is getting a Muslim to become a Jew for
me
Palestine coming in no you know what I
think uh
I would marry a Jew I would also marry a
non-jew but I do want here's the thing
what about a black we'll get it we'll
get a menorah for Hanukkah but I'm cool
with the Christmas tree and also the
kids are going to be Jewish if I'm the
dad let's be real they're gonna pick up
on a lot of [ __ ] a lot of Judaism is
cultural that's true taste and
mannerisms and behavior did you have
Shabbat Shabbat growing up no we weren't
that religious see if he's a very loose
Jew I'm a Loser yeah someone seen my
butthole so uh I just can't wait for
your kids four-year-old my back
baby foods off the jungle gym oh I got a
hernia my neck [ __ ]
oh and my digestion I think I'm the only
comic who has Pepto-Bismol on his rider
uh well let's see really I do I have
caviar for two in my ride and no one's
ever given it to me right there tell
that to Eddie Griffin well we do do a
drinking podcast I have chugged that
many times before we have to drink on
this because like sometimes we come and
hung over and I'm like dude I had spicy
Chinese food the night before we drank
you know it is one of those you
literally will drink Pepto yeah Rick
Glassman gives me endless [ __ ] for this
he's like you should be taking
peppermint pills I'm like perfect
he outdoed me
you should just drink every other night
no we don't do it every night but we try
it's an addiction you can't just tell it
you got a problem
yeah you're all right uh I just realized
every baby is Jewish you bring him to a
restaurant they're like
they spit up they hate the food yeah
that's my bit for the week the baby send
it back
you're funny we're fans we're glad you
uh We're Glad You Came yeah this week
great I'm literally this is how much we
wanted you on the pot I'm moving in the
morning I want I was like I want Natasha
in here oh well thank you for having me
no we're glad you're here and yeah buy
the book see Natasha on tour check out
our podcast yeah endless honeymoon's uh
hilarious this was all in November and
uh Natasha Leggero have a podcast
together called endless honeymoon they
give you advice it's good advice
and leave your deepest darkest secrets
you can also just go to YouTube and you
can get all the information if you can
hear me uh above Mark burping last one
uh you keep saying that it's like and
you're like okay it's all right it's
cute uh
hey you know what you just got married
so you're living your life you got that
right honestly it's okay with her oh
she's a farter
and a Quaver wait she's farted in front
of you and you've only been married for
four days she was farting in front of me
a weekend that's how I knew she was the
one
well that's good yeah that was it and
she was sitting on my face all the time
stop it it was a fun gag I gagged now we
know we've this this one's run its
course yeah the literal gag yeah there
you go
buy her book The World deserves my
children can you get where can you get
it um
yeah natashalajara.com definitely this
comic make sure to pick up a bottle
I will be at a Tacoma Spokane Oklahoma
City and then uh bigger tour starts New
Orleans Austin Tulsa Dallas the Saint
Louis uh the I will never meet a woman
tour in Las Vegas he's bringing his
Pepto lady Seattle Portland Salt Lake
Atlantic City Royal Oak quite a tour
Minneapolis Madison Milwaukee New Haven
Boston he just had a newborn
Miami Orlando Jacksonville Atlanta
Charleston Durham Charlottesville
Norfolk DC Wilkes bar and Port Chester
and oh [ __ ] samuel.com shows loving it
hey we're in Buffalo we're at Cubs
Comedy Club we're at the Wilbur we're at
Zanies we're uh the Blue Note in Hawaii
and then I gotta update my website
because my uh
uh my website person's a pothead but
we'll get on comedy.com oh yeah I'm in
Miami I'm coming everywhere it's gonna
be fun it'll be a good time can't wait
praise I'll uh uh love you beard you
what do you got to promote buddy oh I
got some Vermont right now is uh I'm at
say less right now and uh paper plane
NYC for all your hospitality needs are
you like a traveling bartender
um a uh bartender and bar consultant so
I can help you build your bars come hit
me up yeah by the way speaking of bars
and liquor
specs in Texas over 200 liquor stores
carrying Bodega cat right now just
legalized in Texas it's moving yep
Bodega had spreading I think by the end
of December the shit's gonna be legal in
New York City and hopefully you can
drink it the comedy seller very soon
it's going to be everywhere and uh shout
out to Gotham Studios Matt Peters uh for
everything we [ __ ] love you uh akoi
everybody here sail accused
Natasha Natasha get her book love you
and uh all right we'll see you guys very
soon
gallery
[Music]
[Music]
and I get down in the same way
with my
[Music]